if enough
[Music]
good liberals whoever is out there that
if you are just a good borderline
liberal or someone who's not
particularly political you just have to
not vote for democrats right now you
must vote for republicans for now and
then we can pick up the pieces after
that's where we're at so i want to link
that to one of the things that i've been
talking about a lot over the last month
uh something from bill maher as you know
he was on the joe rogan podcast a couple
weeks ago and even he
is actually starting to get it and i am
really doing my best to push him to
fully
accept
the truth
i mean i say this all the time because
the uh
percentage of
graft keeps getting
higher and higher now we found out
recently that something like oh i'm
going to get the number wrong maybe you
can look it up on your magic light box
but
like 20
i think of the uh unemployment checks we
passed out during covet were complete
fraud mere pittance
[Laughter]
the uh ppp yeah oh my god so many people
got arrested for having lamborghinis and
[ __ ] right
i mean jk rowling got money no she did
it yeah for her broadway show what
because if she didn't she'd be living in
her car joe ah
she got money from that that's hilarious
everybody got money tom brady so crazy
and like
when you look at some of the percent and
like the number for uh to build a house
for the homeless in l.a
has risen to
thirty 837 thousand amir pittance bill
maher
amir pins from these greedy billionaires
out there we need to talk to them all if
i'm complaining about that again to your
point about a republican idea people
would say oh you're complaining about
government spending money and my answer
is okay but is there any number at which
point i am not
tipped over into the republican side
right that i can't complain about money
that is just being stolen
right i mean we i i totally as a good
liberal i totally accept the notion that
as someone once said you cannot transfer
money except with a leaky bucket i get
it it can't be perfect
but
is it
20 what is that is there no number
for which i cannot remonstrate against
right
ah he's so close
no bill there is no number your guys the
guy that you supported joe biden the
party that you support there is no
number that will ever be enough they
make up the numbers
they pour money onto all of these
programs that destroy the very place
that you live in los angeles that has
been destroyed by homelessness and drug
use and crime they usher in all of those
things and i get it he's saying well i'm
in essence he's saying i'm a guilty
liberal so i still want to do these
things get over it man like you gotta
get over it otherwise they will all show
up at your multi-million dollar house
one day that's just how it is and you'll
have no one to blame but yourself when
you call the police and say boy there's
an awful lot of antifa people and
homeless people and everything else
climbing over the gate right now i'm
very upset about this also i just want
to say one sort of side thing and maybe
this is me at 45 years old as i said it
is middle age what can i do uh and and i
guess having become a little more
conservative
over the years but there's something
about watching people smoke pot and have
a conversation that seems very
sort of gross to me i'm not against pot
and occasionally i smoke some weed and i
watch seinfeld and i go to bed that's
pretty much my pot experience these days
and and people can smoke pot for any
reason they want but there's something
about like you're you got two guys here
who are pretty freaking influential in
the world what's the reason they have to
get stoned to have that conversation i
don't know do i man do i get i sound
like a stodgy old i sound like mr burns
or something [ __ ]